ja also ich meine ich treffe immer mehr
Menschen ich weiß nicht ob es Ihnen auch
so geht die mir sagen sie haben das
Gefühl sie werden von verrückten regiert
und ich meine so weit würde ich jetzt
vielleicht nicht gehen aber ich muss
sagen ich habe wirklich auch Zweifel an
der demokratischen Verfasstheit eines
Landes wenn eine Regierung permanent und
Penne drant gegen die nach Umfragen ja
durchaus messbaren Wünsche und
Interessen der Menschen regiert und bei
der bei diesem Heizungs Irrsinn ist es
ja ganz klar forza hat das ermittelt 78%
der Bundesbürger lehnen das ab die
wollen dieses Gesetz nicht und sie haben
alle Argumente auf ihrer Seite ich meine
die sind ja bekannt man kann
ältere Gebäude nicht effizient mit
Wärmepumpen beheizen wenn man das
versucht dann gehen die Energiekosten
noch mehr durch die Decke und man sitzt
trotzdem in lauwarm Räumen außerdem hat
Deutschland nur mal einen Strom Mix wo
im Winter und das wird jetzt nach
Abschaltung der Atomkraftwerke erst
recht zu sein der überwiegende Teil des
Stroms aus fossilen Energieträgern kommt
das heißt die Leute soll immenseem
Aufwand am Ende eine Heizung
installieren die mit Kohle und Gasstrom
betrieben wird was das für ein Irrsinn
und dann kommt jetzt noch ein Argument
dazu dass im Grunde das ganze völlig ad
absurdum führt der Konzern vonovia hat
ja vor kurzem öffentlich gemacht dass er
installierte Wärmepumpen gar nicht ans
Netz bringen kann weil die Kapazitäten
nicht ausreichen und der Chef der Netz
der Bundesnetzagentur das habe ich jetzt
gelesen und das muss ich gleich finde
dass das schlägt dem fast den Boden aus
das ist ja auch ein grüner der Deal
zurzeit mit der Bundesregierung das ist
ein Gesetz gibt dass ihm ermöglicht ab
nächstem Jahr Strom zu rationieren das
heißt dass er dann in Spitzen Zeiten
Wärmepumpen und E-Autos also die
gefeierten Zukunftstechnologien vom Netz
nehmen darf weil die Netze überhaupt
nicht in der Lage sind habe zu Millionen
Wärmepumpen die wir jetzt alle
installieren sollen überhaupt mit Strom
zu beliefern das heißt zum Dank dafür
dass die Leute mit ganz viel Geld diese
Sachen einbauen in ihre Häuser wird
Ihnen dann wahrscheinlich ab nächsten
Jahr der Strom abgestellt also ich muss
sagen era geht's nicht und das finde ich
wirklich so kann man doch nicht Politik
machen und das können eigentlich nur
Leute die sich völlig die völlig die
Bodenhaftung verloren haben die nur noch
mit ihren ideologischen Glaubensbrüdern
kommunizieren und die irgendwie ihre
Blase mit mit der Welt verwechseln und
dass da natürlich zwischen ideologischer
Inzucht und Clanwirtschaft auch nur noch
ein ganz schmaler gratis das haben wir
inzwischen ja auch gelernt und ich finde
das kann so nicht weitergehen was
befürchten sie wenn das so weitergeht
wenn das Thema angesprochen der
Wohlstandsverlust sie Industrialisierung
Unternehmen die abwandern lassen Sie uns
gemeinsam in die Zukunft schauen was
sind da ihre Sorgen wenn das darf nicht
so weitergehen ich meine das ist jetzt
sonst ein Land kann sich doch nicht so
kaputt machen weil die Leute werden
immer frustriert werden wenn die
Industrie abwandern so wie sich das
zurzeit ankündigt das hat jetzt weniger
mit den Wärmepumpen zu tun als insgesamt
mit den hohen Stromkosten mit den hohen
Energie Reisen auch mit dem
Bildungssystem in Deutschland
Fachkräftemangel ist ein ganz sie waren
ja auch bei ThyssenKrupp und haben sich
dort für noch mal um die haben ja auch
gesagt ja die haben zum Beispiel auch
gesagt ja toll wir sollen jetzt grünen
also wasserstoffstahl produzieren wir
kriegen weder ausreichend Wasserstoff
noch kriegen wir ausreichend grünen
Strom und außerdem ist die Technologie
zur Zeit so dass die Preise natürlich
nicht wettbewerbsfähig sind wie sollen
wir eigentlich überleben und sie haben
gesagt ja die Zertifikate die werden so
teuer werden dass sie tatsächlich mit
den alten Technologien bald auch nicht
mehr produzieren können und da frage ich
mich auch ich meine diese Zertifikate da
wird immer gesagt ja auch bei den
Wärmepumpen ja das wird ja sonst die
Gasheizung wird ja nicht mehr
erschwinglich und die Ölheizung weil
alles so teuer wird ja das macht doch
die gleiche Politik das machen die doch
andere Länder machen das nicht außerhalb
der EU die USA macht sowas nicht die USA
subventioniert dass sie dort
zukunftsindustrie holen und wir
zuständig Unternehmen dann wir zerstören
unsere Industrie na klar die wandern die
ab und ich ich hoffe einfach dass die
Politik irgendwann wieder Verstand kommt
oder dass Parteien an die Regierung
kommt die bei Verstand sind aber so kann
es nicht weitergehen Frau kellerie haben
ich habe gehört oft gesagt und auch
gelegt sein
klassisch ihre politische Linie aber sie
stimmen da glaube ich höre ich raus ja
weil es weil es tatsächlich ich frage
mich immer wie lange es noch dauern wird
bis tatsächlich mal Menschen auf die
Straße gehen die wirklich ein Problem
haben weil das was im Moment ja auf der
Straße klebt sind ja quasi Menschen die
irgendwie Wohlstandsverwahrlosung hinter
sich haben und irgendwie Probleme suchen
müssen aber ich hoffe sehr dass die
Leute endlich begreifen und
möglicherweise braucht es jetzt
sozusagen diese schlimmen Zustände damit
sie begreifen dass diese diese Regierung
sie komplett enteignet das was hier
passiert auf einer Ebene also jetzt
gerade wenn man zum Beispiel diese also
nur die zwei Faktoren nimmt dass man
sagt Verbrenner Motoren verbieten und
nur noch eh Autos und ähm
Kohle und Gas nicht mehr heizen sondern
nur noch Wärmepumpen also alles mit
Strom um dann jetzt schon darüber
nachzudenken wie man uns den Strom
abstellen darf ja das heißt sie drängen
uns jetzt dazu unsere unsere
verbrennerautos abzuschaffen dass wir
sie nicht mehr fahren dürfen die werden
verboten sie verbieten uns das Heizen
mit Gas und Kohle und dann sagen sie und
jetzt rationieren wir wie viel Strom ihr
noch verbrauchen wird mit Verlaub ich
bin in Rumänien geboren ich kenne das
noch mit dem stationierten Strom das
tagsüber irgendwie Wasser und Strom
abgestellt wurden das ist klassisch
Planwirtschaft der alles was gerade
passiert ist immer theoretisch sitzt da
irgendein Idiot in irgendeine
Ministerium und macht einen Plan wie das
alles funktioniert soll und nicht einmal
theoretisch funktioniert das und
praktisch wird es auch nicht
funktionieren und man drängt die Leute
im moment in einen in ein die Politik
drängt sie im Endeffekt das mitzumachen
und ich hoffe sehr dass die Leute
wirklich auf die Straße gehen und ich
hoffe sehr auch irgendwie ähm ich glaube
dass jetzt wo es auf ähm den Leuten als
Eigenheim geht dass diejenigen die hart
gearbeitet haben um sie ihr Eigenheim zu
kaufen um um ein kleines reinhäuschen
abzubezahlen und jetzt nicht wissen wie
sie diese Umrüstung die man ihnen
zwangsweise auferlegt irgendwie um noch
heizen zu können das ist wie eine
Enteignung und ich glaube dass das
Wahlverhalten doch endlich kippen wird
und wenn man merkt selbst die Grünen in
Baden-Württemberg irgendwie die ja nun
eher ein konservatives Publikum auch
haben auch in ihrer Wählerschaft ich
glaube da sind ja sozusagen die
schwabene die Häuslebauer ja ich glaube
die Häuslebauer sind langsam nicht mehr
richtig gut drauf
teilen Sie diese Sorgen fühlen sie sich
bevormundet bei diesen Themen also ich
muss sagen ich sehe hier Frauen in der
Runde die sich sehr intensiv mit diesem
Thema befasst haben und ich muss ehrlich
sagen dass es nicht das Kompetenz Thema
in dem ich mich alltäglich bewege aber
ähm was ich ja auf jeden Fall spüre ist
das nicht nur bei diesem Thema auch
insgesamt habe ich öfter das Gefühl von
Bevormundungen in verschiedenen Bereich
nicht nur in der Bundesregierung auch in
anderen davor und ich finde einen ja
mehr mit Sprache recht für die
Bürgerinnen und Bürger Prozess nicht
ganz gut Zufriedenheit
gibt die sagen wie Frau Wagenknecht das
gerade gesagt hat die Politik eigentlich
die Bodenhaftung den Kontakt zu den
Menschen verloren also ich empfinde so
ein Gefühl übrigens durchweg ja also ich
finde ganz oft dass die Politiker die
weit oben sind nicht ganz genau
verstehen oder fühlen wie es sage ich
mal sich on the ground für den einfachen
Bürger anfühlt und hier in diesem Punkt
scheint es ähnlich zu sein und ich werde
die Politik damit die Menschen auch
immer mehr zu AFD die hat jetzt gute
Umfrage werden mit 17 % teilweise
bundesweit glauben Sie dass das auch
quasi eine eigene Verantwortung
grundsätzlich ist das so dass wenn die
Menschen hier in einer in der Demokratie
das Gefühl haben dass ihre Gesetze ihre
demokratischen Vertreter gewisse Dinge
über ihre Köpfe hinweg entscheiden oder
sie nicht richtig verstehen dann lockt
sie das irgendwie leider
in die Hände solcher Parteien die dann
behaupten sie hätten die Lösung und so
weiter aber am Ende des Tages ist es
genau das was wir nicht wollen wir
wollen doch nicht diese Menschen
verlieren deswegen glaube ich das ganz
wichtig da die Boden haben Haftung
aufrecht zu halten und nachzufragen wie
die Menschen sich dann eigentlich bei
diesen ganzen Dingen fühlen und wie ich
herausföhre in dieser Runde auf
pragmatische Lösungen anzubieten Frau
Wagenknecht gehen sie soweit dass sie
jetzt ganz klar sagen würden dann
brauchen wir eben die Atomkraft
also ich sag mal ich glaube einfach dass
die Wärmepumpe auch mit der Atomkraft
nicht unbedingt Sinn macht weil die
Probleme der Gebäude und des Umbaus und
sind die bleiben ja trotzdem also ich
habe ein bisschen eine Sorge wenn man
jetzt noch die Atomkraft ist jetzt die
neue Heiztechnologie weil sie hat eben
sehr sehr starke Risiken wenn Sie
problemlos funktioniert ist alles okay
aber ich wohne zum Beispiel der Nähe
eines sehr alten französischen
Atomkraftwerks nämlich von kathenomen
hat immer wieder Störfälle und ehrlich
gesagt ich möchte mir nicht ausmalen
wenn es da mal ein größeren störfer gibt
ich glaube sowieso dass es es wird in
Zukunft andere Technologien geben und
ich finde wir müssen viel mehr
investieren in die Erforschung also
vielleicht wird es der für unsere Aktor
vielleicht wird es andere Bereiche aber
ich meine aber aber wie sie sagen das
Problem ist doch dass wir ausgestiegen
sind auch aus der Forschung also man
muss ja einfach mal in Deutschland das
zentrale nein nein ich ich glaube dass
diese dieser deutsche Sonderweg sich aus
der Atomkraft zu verabschieden der
größte Irrsinn ist also wir können ja
nicht alle gleichzeitig aus allen
Energieformen aussteigen um eine
Atomstrom übrigens irgendwie auch aus ja
es ist ja eben nicht so dass man sagt
wie wir steigen aus Atomstrom aus
sondern wir sind auf ihren nachbaratom
Kraftwerk ja durchaus angewiesen und
dann wäre es mir ehrlich gesagt lieber
wir betreiben ein sicheres anstatt dass
wir es dass wir darauf angewiesen sind
dass unsere Nachbarn unter ihren eigenen
Bedingungen mit ihren eigenen
Sicherheitsvorkehrungen das ganze machen
das ist ja der Blödsinn wir hatten die
sichersten Atomkraftwerke weltweit und
die schalten wir ab und jetzt den
Atomstrom in stechen und den Frankreich
und überall zu kaufen und mitverlauf
auch Atomkraftwerke sind nicht mehr sind
sozusagen in den letzten Jahrzehnten
sicherer geworden diese diese
Entwicklung geht ja deutlich weiter das
heißt für mich wäre die Lösung nicht
abschalten was wir entwickeln können
oder was wir sicherer machen können
zumal wenn wir keine Alternative haben
also es ist ja ja die ganze die ganze
Welt baut Atomkraftwerke baut inzwischen
sicherer Atom können Sie mir sagen was
den letzten atomaren Zwischenfall
weltweit gegeben hat ich kann mich nicht
erinnern
überzeugt kriegen wir jetzt im Jahr für
Atomkraft von Frau Wagenknecht sie hat
natürlich insoweit völlig recht also
dass wir das ist auch eine verlogene
Politik ist weil wir ja zum Beispiel
Atomstrom aus Frankreich importieren und
mit unserem Energiemix gar nicht zu
handeln können ich wäre auch der Meinung
gewesen die drei Kraftwerke die wir
hatten die hätten wir jetzt weiterlaufen
lassen müssen in der Situation die wir
haben also die Vorstellung der Grünen
dass wir jetzt alles über Sonne und Wind
abdecken und im Winter scheint eben die
Sonne wenig und ab und an wird auch der
Wind nicht das ist idiotisch ich glaube
trotzdem dass die Zukunftstechnologien
andere sein werden weil auch der Atom
Müll z.B ein ungelöstes Problem ist
niemand will ein Endlager in seiner Nähe
haben und die Rotoren Blätter von von
den von den Windmühlen gelagert werden
ja richtig strahlen wenigstens die
Strahlen nicht aber nein trotzdem wie
gesagt ich wäre ja dafür die drei Dinger
hätte man laufen lassen müssen weil
damit wäre zumindest die Grundlast
abgesichert gewesen aber perspektivisch
brauchen wir andere Technologien und ich
glaube das Kernproblem ist dass wir dort
viel zu wenig in die Forschung in
passieren dass wir viel zu wenig da
reinsetzen hier weiterzukommen sondern
dass tatsächlich die grüne diese
Ideologie pflegen also wir müssen jetzt
nur noch mehr solarm möglichst alle
Felder sollen jetzt mit Solarflächen
abgedeckelt werden und überall wo noch
ein Naturschutzgebiet ist müssen die
Windräder rein und dann haben wir unser
Stromproblem gelöst das ist völlig
absurd so wird es nicht laufen und
deswegen brauchen wir da andere Lösungen
aber das wärmepumpenproblem wie gesagt
ist damit noch nicht gelöst weil da sind
ja die ganzen Umbauten die damit zu tun
haben das bleibt ja trotzdem und
deswegen brauchen wir auch für die z.B
gibt es andere Länder die das Heiz
Problem viel intelligenter gelöst haben
die haben sehr viel Fernwärme und bei
Fernwärme haben sie tatsächlich
erneuerbare Quellen dafür die nutzen
teilweise die Wärme aus Abwasser oder
andere Dinge also es gibt ganz kreative
es geht intelligente Lösungen wenn man
darüber nachdenkt und insoweit würde ich
noch nicht mal sagen es ist noch nicht
mal Planwirtschaft die haben keinen Plan
die haben ja noch nicht mal den Plan wie
sie ausreichend Strom zur Verfügung
stellen um ihre ganzen tollen
Wärmepumpen Fotos zu betreiben sondern
die machen einfach Aktionismus
wieder Wahlkampfrede glauben Sie dass
die Regierung wackelt und wenn ja wie
sieht es denn mit der eigenen Partei aus
ich glaube man denkt immer Regierungen
wackeln die wackeln noch lange nicht
also gerade eine Partei wie die Grünen
jetzt so abschmiert die klebt natürlich
in der Regierung weil wenn die jetzt
Neuwahlen hätten würden sie richtig
Sitze verlieren deswegen soll man die
verfügten Hoffnung dass die Ampel jetzt
ja bald sich auflöst die habe ich nicht
also ich glaube die nächste Wahl wird 24
sein und wahrscheinlich nicht früher
aber ich hoffe natürlich dass es da bis
dahin irgendwie was in Bewegung kommt
das hoffe ich schon also auch mit ihrer
Partei was in Bewegung kommt
naja gut ob meine eigenen Partei das ist
ja aktuell die Linke viel in Bewegung
kommt das wird man sehen aber ich hoffe
dass ich insgesamt im Parteien Spektrum
was bewegt mit einer eigenen neuen
Partei gucken wir mal